me too hello and welcome everybody to
the h3 podcast thank you to manscaping
and me on DS response Rex today we have
the return of the great bill Bert what's
up guys congratulations
beautiful baby boy Louie why she's
glowing I know she is she really is did
she show you pictures I saw yeah we did
the whole thing yeah it looks like you
yep definitely I think so yeah he's a
chubby he's chubby we have that in
common good thing for a baby yeah you
know it's the only time in your life you
can be chubby yeah
no enjoy it - it's like when when those
little rolls go away you know the little
sausage links go like my daughter used
to have like one right in the middle of
her for I was like what is that
now she's all like leaning out mm-hm
running around and stuff but it's all
she's hilarious
this morning I did Kimmel the other day
and I and I wanted it just like I wanted
to show something to my wife and she was
watching like Muppet Babies this morning
I was like hey you want to see Dad down
TV she's like no that's the special
thing though no matter how famous no
matter who you are kids you're just dad
well I mean Muppet Babies is pretty
funny my that's true I love my babies
you can't yeah any any kids show that it
is empathetic enough to throw like adult
Joe is like some jokes in there for you
to just what I always liked about Sesame
Street as I got older and you know and
you know my little brothers or whatever
would be watching it right there was a
whole new viewing of it like oh man I
got a lot of jokes in here for all the
people too so my well yeah
before we get too deep I want you know
that when the guy came in to get the
musical instrument and he asked for some
instrument he goes off you're one of
those walk doing is just like what is he
that was
even me there's gonna be in a
pain-in-the-ass customer it was just
funny
I haven't said I guess I'm good to
relive all of these childhood classics
as Theodore gets older gonna be I'm
excited you get to rewash all the Disney
films you get to rewatch the Sesame
Street's was there any of those that
were your well the Sesame Street's the
classic ones I mean I you know I was
born in 68 so when I first started
watching it three or four the show was
only like three or four years old it
came out the same year I was born so I
saw all the classics and was Jim Henson
doing the voices and the Cookie Monster
was eating cookies I know he went for a
while but then then he came back yeah
this is you know those about feeding
cookies you know nine people complain
now ready get scare my god you know the
Cookie Monster can eat cookies I would
have just said why you fat shaming his
name no they didn't change his name the
whole thing was just weird I mean now it
wasn't sort of half paying attention to
that but he's back to like eating
cookies or whatever but it's just shows
just been on so long that a lot of
people who did the voices have retired
or passed on so it's a little bit
different and uh you know I actually we
just started watching again and the
Morean Lewis is still there mr. Hooper
obviously is long gone I didn't see
David a bob on there it's been a long
time no but it was just crazy like Luis
and Maria were living together my god
but uh-oh still a huge fan well I want
to first of all celebrate your new
comedy special streaming on Netflix
right now paper tiger which I had the
pleasure of washing so funny so thank
you I feel like it was just just so it
was just like a such an entertaining
wonderful piece of comedy I don't I I
felt like you weren't trying to be
provocative or offend anyone
yeah just having fun yeah and I think
like some time anyway I appreciate
well I mean I was in that amazing venue
and I had the added nervousness of being
in a different country and I going to it
was a stupid was this a mistake and it
was London but it yeah it ended up being
like just was was was a you know it was
a great time and then like Mike binder
you just did such a great job and
healing he watched the hour like like 10
different times he just kept coming to
shows like this guy's crazy but he knew
the hours so well that he knew how to
who's at the director yes sorry yeah the
director so so you did how many so is
that how it works where you did a bunch
of shows and they cut it up no he went
to go see me a bunch of times and I I
did like I think I did one show Monday
and then I did a show Tuesday mmm it's
how it works so it's kind of weird we're
usually you just do two and one night
and you get the warm up and then it's
usually the second show and then when
you're making your edits should just
take a little bit here and a little bit
by I try to do it you know as much as I
can all one show so it doesn't like you
start to notice when you jump back and
forth and they're all so I'm not trying
I'm trying
as much as possible to show a show that
I did not create a show that never
happened right because then it gets to
smoothed out through slick and
everything like the mistakes and
everything are the are the things that
give it like the personality and I love
that you left in like the the part about
the mic you know messing up the
continuity because the piece of the
microphone why s-- we I looked at it
like twice I people you know when quote
and Joe is like I forgot about there was
that great more the women the women or
not heckler but somebody screamed
something from the audience about
consent I was just great yeah when that
happens all the time like people sit
there and how they hear something is
what you're saying and then you're
directly attacking them and it's yeah
it's just such a you know it's just a
weird time yeah it is a weird time I've
heard you saying that a lot in inner
with Joe Rogan's last special with
strange time what
which was perfect right I try to look
like I keep wanting to say strange time
but it was never special so yeah it is
it's just it's bizarre it's a bizarre
time you know I had this chunk to where
I was making fun of that support the
troops sing and I get like just the
conspiracy theories as to why that
wasn't in there
mmm it was like oh he totally puts it
out because his special came out
September 10th and September love you
didn't with the heat it's like no this
special was too long and you have and
not to mention that night I mean it went
well but it didn't go as great as it
always did and I was like what the [ __ ]
happened in that part of the show hmm
and what happened was I guess the IRA
sent a threat that there was a bunch of
bombs around London that day so just a
little weird different tone in it and I
didn't know what it was uh yet nobody
told me because I go don't tell the
talent cuz you don't have to I was they
do it and they would love that
yeah but nobody did so I was just sort
of confused and I'm like you know going
it never [ __ ] fails the kills a
hundred percent of the time then the
night of the special somebody [ __ ]
falls off a chair or something so I just
sort of plowed through it and but I I
recorded at Madison Square Garden and
it's gonna be you know be releasing that
maybe sometime next year or something
like that I just got the album cover
it's gonna be singing and ass gonna be a
double album it's gonna be so sick and
but that that bits on there so now that
makes it kind of cool I was talking to
somebody that's sort of like my legs
Appling like my hey hey what can I do
just something that just didn't make the
album but just watching somebody just
you know liking the joke so much that it
wasn't there that they then just took
this thing and just ran with it I just
you know I I was like wow man I do that
I do that all the time so I don't
necessarily get like upset with that
thing but the person's watching or
whatever that's what happened like we
made the decision way before we even
knew what the date was because Netflix
doesn't even yeah like they're just like
they don't tell you when it's coming
yeah they're like the Federal Reserve
information and find like a member
like okay what day so yeah so I had
nothing to do with that and in Mike was
just going like dude you know this host
special is about you and that that thing
there kind of doesn't fit it's just sort
of this aside so I was like I fought him
I said you know I don't think so I don't
I want to keep the whole thing I want to
just have the whole thing you know
typical artists everything and then when
we took it out I was just like it just
flowed and then it also you know it was
kind of home and it went from like you
know we got our and 20 or something like
that down like an hour and five or hour
and six and then it just flew I got in I
got out it made you wish it was longer
and that's what you want to leave you
don't to be like very true I I do I want
there's a lot of calmly specials that if
you start to feel the length the
direction but like the bet even want
more that's what you did don't worry you
did it
I watched the whole thing with joy and
pleasure and when it came where'd the
time go on Netflix right now why did you
do it in a in London two reasons I'm a
huge Led Zeppelin fan and my favorite
footage is of them at Royal Albert Hall
and the first time I played there you
know I think I was just a little freaked
out that I was standing on that stage
because it really looks the same as that
concert footage for most you know forty
five years ago or something and we were
just over there and we were like you
know I mean I've done a special in New
York I did one in San Francisco you know
I've done them down south I did one in
DC and you know right on the friggin
mason-dixon line essentially and it's
just so nowhere now where do I go now
where would it be different in
everywhere you go the crowd has like a
different vibe it's weird like like the
the laughs sound different stuff that
they react to and then so then you have
to adjust while you're on stage and then
that makes you present mmm I find it
works for me so and then the other side
was me and Mike binder smoked cigars and
he just wanted
to smoke a cigar with me in London he
normally directs like you know major
movies and he just you know as this
one-off was like I'll direct your
special yeah most smoke a cigar after
it'll be great and that's how kind of
what don't what everything looked
amazing I think yeah he did oh that you
know I I love hearing that
I love yeah that was definitely
something that we took time and you know
it's it's kind of something that I was
working towards through all of my
specials and I've worked with a lot of
great people I'd you know like the last
like two or three I did with Jake Harris
and and then this one I'm I've worked
you know Mike binder on on this one and
I don't know them I'm happy with it
yeah I noticed you I not that I'm
criticizing because sometimes it works
by like it starts you're on stage
there's no intro sketch or anything like
that and then it ends and you're off
stages there's a lot of different things
that comedians start doing now where
they're it's kind of putting stuff in
the beginning and end but I hear you
made that not just choice to do that
night yeah I've always got too much [ __ ]
I want to say yes other people though it
works yeah it's just one of those things
yeah like you know and some people joke
about this and some people joke about
that yeah like it's sort of the whole
thing so oh by the way on tour
billboard.com get that out of the way
mandalorian apparently you can't talk
about it but you I can't say what
happens okay you can't say what happens
but tell me what you can let's let's say
that um I can tell you it looks sick
like everybody else like I've always
been like a sports fan and I I was you
know I didn't grow up on Star Wars like
I kind of by the time I discovered it
was out there I was more into my Fast
Times at Ridgemont High
so do you know teenage years so and they
were in the Ewoks at that point so it
just didn't connect yeah and but I did
Empire Strikes Back I did like so I
don't know I just how the hell did it
come together just over the years are
getting to know Mike binder and working
with Vince Vaughn's company on and
Peter Billingsley what f is for family
mm-hmm eventually you're gonna meet John
Favreau
which I did and that's how I ended up
doing in that episode of his cooking
show mm-hmm great a good time you get
alum so much as his business is meeting
somebody it's like I like this guy could
be on the sell this guy 14 hours a day
14 sometimes and I was at Mike binders
birthday party and John was there he
said hey man he goes I'm doing the next
hours I wow that's great
he goes uh would you ever want to do
like a partner so Mike and I kind of
laughed I was like who do you know I
always make fun of those Star Wars I
know every time when those movies comes
out you know just to be a dick and you
guys know I think it would be funny
because I can be funny of people that
listen your podcasts actually saw you on
that no no I was this like really my
wife was like yes say yes Mike Star Wars
was like the Magnificent Seven
it was like The Great Escape bridge over
the River Kwai Cool Hand Luke
that's what I grew up on those those
were the the movies that I loved and I
loved all of those you know Kelly's
heroes all of that stuff is with the
stuff the Dirty Dozen mm-hmm and all of
those that's what I grew up on and
that's what I loved and so I I don't
know I just I didn't understand this is
the magnitude yeah of something like
that because Jon just kept laughing at
me goes dude you don't understand it
yeah it's the booth and I wanted this
super creepy thing will you just stand
there and there's like a zillion like
this is just like you know when they go
to do the action figure thing like this
like or like greater your body right
camera camera camera camera camera can
just give away my DNA yeah yeah that was
weird so what's the purpose of that to
CGI your body like that seems pretty
serious I don't know I don't know what
it is just sort of let in there and
that's kind of what you did it is they
make an action figure or something yeah
we're gonna get the home I don't know
that was uh it sounds pretty serious let
me ask you this are you know I'll tell
you this but then I when I went down
there it was
Rick Rick family wah is the one who
directed it and he just wished I don't
want to say how he was she about how he
was shooting it was so cool and it was
like I mean you saw the trailer you know
yeah super heads on stakes this is yeah
it's just like was it was a badass was
this the craziest shoot you've been on I
mean it doesn't really get crazier
budgets and Star Wars does it I know it
I don't know like there was a room that
they had I mean I mean yeah are you
allowed to talk about the technology yes
it's like you walked into the room and
then the door closed around you and you
were just surrounded by this giant green
screen and then they just projected like
all this stuff the whole world yeah so
you'd be talking to somebody if I move
like this like the background moved
behind like yeah I heard they had I
heard it's they the highest budget show
ever made right dan what was the budget
on that thing like 25 million is like 15
or 20 mil in episode like more than Game
of Thrones I gotta tell you this if you
see the tria like he should when he
showed me the trailer cuz you know
you're always you know you're just like
this close to it you don't even know
what's going on and also they just give
you like your sides for the scene you
don't know what's going on for the most
part and then like on my last day
fortunately my episode I think was far
enough into the season where they had a
rough cut of the trailer hmm and he
showed it to the whole crew on that big
round thing and the last scene I was
doing I was way up on this I don't know
what the hell it is scaffolding type
thing so I was standing up there just
watching this the size of a brownstone
you know rejection of it and I was just
saying that's not that's when I got
excited that and I was and I went from
like hey this is pretty cool to like oh
my god I can't believe I'm gonna be in
this yeah and but it's funny because I
got a bunch of friends of mine who don't
care about sports that are totally
like nerding out for this thing so they
they were just like Joe DeRosa who is
not into sports at all remember years
ago he said to me hey you know I yeah he
goes I had drinks with this guy the
other night he's he works for the
Yankees I was just like Joe Torre you
had [ __ ] drinks with Joe Torre Joe
probably loves everything about so many
baseball question yeah so when he gave
me [ __ ] about being in it yeah you gotta
be kidding you're in this [ __ ] with the
don't even watch these movies and blah
blah blah I was just like Joe you had
drinks with Joe Torre he was just like
that's the universe coming back to me so
but it was it was like it was really
like really fun scenes a lot of lot to
go a lot going on and the people other
actors that I got to work with it was
pretty it was pretty ha I'm not gonna
let he was pretty intense
there's definitely long days like a lot
of stuff like that but it was yeah I
think it's gonna be I think it's gonna
be sick I'm excited I kind of have this
this running theme if you look at my
IMDB page mm-hmm where I sort of somehow
paratroop into these really cool games
but like I said Breaking Bad the most
accomplished IMDB yeah without really
yeah that's the thing I always feel like
them when I get on these things I won
like a radio contest I don't even know
what the reference is this tower was
it's a place stormtrooper I guess yeah
yeah you nailed it and see you're part
of the you're in now oh man I I you know
I was thinking I was like there's no way
that Disney is gonna get me to pony up
for their premium I was like there's no
way I'm arts that's that's the greatest
money that they could hide out in that
world but I did a thing one time at
comic-con when Breaking Bad had this
this 10 year thing and they asked me if
I wanted to host it I was like
absolutely totally honored and when I
went down there to comic-con it was just
like it was a whole other war
Christ and the the kids down there
called kids I'm 51 they were like they
were really cool just how like into
shows and how much they appreciated
there was a couple of f is for family
fans down there for some reason we've
never done with an animated show we've
never done a comic-con and I don't like
all the writers and Mike Price
co-creator of the show he really wants
to do it so I'm hoping at some point
that'd be great yeah we get to go down
there because you know they they're it's
the whole universe yeah is you know
there's there's people that grew up
reading the comics and I I'm not I
wasn't into it but I've heard people
describing it like Howard Stern not
listened to and he talks about he grew
up on comics like they were his you know
second dad he was oh yeah it's like
really that ingrained so yeah you're in
my siblings were really into him yeah
comic books I never quite got into I
like the drawings me too yeah I read how
strong they look at me that's strong but
I just want to go outside and play I've
never read one but I had a few just for
the drawings yeah there you go
the uh let me see I wanna I want to talk
to you about childbirth because I know
we have that in common none that we've
given birth yeah but but the act of
being a father's and and mothers in this
case I always hear people saying that
the best day of their life was when the
child was born right like you're that
that to me was like one of the worst
longest stressful days of my life yeah
like I just wanted my wife to be out of
pain yeah I mean it's it's it's it's
scary
exactly you I mean Ellis hooked up to
like the matrix did your wife do the
epidural I do I really don't remember
much I was just like you know you always
see these movies were like you know they
give birth in the car and you have so
much time you have so much like the
water breaks it's just I had a buddy
Maya who's since moved on from running
on the show he he was talking about on
the first one they were like John wick
driving
and then the second time they had a kid
is sick my water broke I go to up
landish watching an episode I was
panicked about that and I was really
freaking out about becoming a dad and
how my life was gonna change and and you
know it's like one of those you know
things were just like am i worthy of
this hmm and and one of my friends said
that with the thing that really stuck
with me goes through the craziest thing
is the day they discharged you and they
give you your baby and you're just
sitting there going like like hair he
goes like I can leave with this yeah
yeah you'll figure it out you know I
liken it to buying a gun I bought a gun
and that's exactly the only ever time I
felt that too right I went and I bought
a shotgun to defend my home hmm and
they're like here you go right I was
like I couldn't leave I don't know how
to use this [ __ ] thing but I got the
same why did you go down to take some
lessons I hope yes I did but they give
you the balls to give you the gun
they're like god Bless America I didn't
know that but the song
those are the only two times I felt that
I think oh my baby and taking all my
shotgun I had that moment right after
delivery when you've finished the whole
delivery part and they're gonna move you
to your own room and we were just the
two of us in the room with the baby and
the last like everyone was leaving and
then the last nurse was like okay so
your room will be over there and we'll
head there and you guys are done and I
was like wait wait is anyone gonna tell
me anything what's next like again just
naturally like getting her home they're
like I wasn't nervous driving down the
highway with her I just wanted to get
her home and then get her in the house
and then once I had her in the house
I was like terrified to go outside the
house with her for a while like I
remember the first time I actually
walked out on the porch with her my
first thought was what if a bird of prey
how I would kill the bird set her down
gently at the same time like you know
action movie files that I working out
and but I found that it's just it
definitely help me at least around the
house like manage my emotions and calm
down a lot more and understand how much
you know my crazy behavior effects you
know I realize how much it was affecting
my wife soon you know having a kid being
on alright I need to chill the [ __ ] out
and stop flipping out over little things
it's not like I yell at people I just
yell about stuff and just being like
yeah like this crazy guy in a bus
station well one day when you see your
kid looking at you for the first time
processing who you are as a person and
it's very embarrassing
yeah just like wow this is what my wife
is print on to explain me for 10 years
and I just thought she was like bitching
at me and then I think she just in the
special the whole bit I'm still thinking
about it again stuff about how you're
just I don't want to say that you're
such a great dad you nailed it on you
know bringing in the money take the
trash out you got it all nailed down but
the only thing is that you can see she
has on me as I would laugh at if it
wasn't so true instead I [ __ ] up so my
it's going great it's going great and
then I just [ __ ] I [ __ ] it up the
other day she goes hey let's go out and
celebrate as a family on your special
okay and I have a pilot's license and
I'm trying to get my instrument rating
so I bought you know I got all excited I
did like this nerdy computer [ __ ] that I
never do I bought a flight simulator
game and I had the yoke Ronal and all of
this stuff and I'm going to upload it
and you know everything's going great
everything's going great until the last
disc and this happens to me every
[ __ ] time and I just was like beside
myself and I just start off with it's
unbelievable it's just unbelievable I
mean how many every [ __ ] time
practice you know you use your cell
phone
I lose a cellphone it's just gone
cell phone a [ __ ] Boy Scout fine to
bring a tea on the pillow and I just
have a ramping up and ramping up and
ramping up and in my head of my Phil
stop it stop it by the time I shut it
down which is way earlier than I usually
do
I had already [ __ ] up the whole day
and I had to have the you know we just
wanted to go out as a family and I have
I know I mean what happened the next day
a nanny comes over it's just like what
just hit reset and start over again the
whole thing so we're gonna attempt again
today with a lunch we'll see how that
goes so whatever well you you you I
guess we're tough were uh at that time
for a break we're about halfway in so
let's throw really or it's been 30
minutes thirty minutes just like the
good times we'll be right back we'll go
to break we'll be right back with the
great bill burr
today I am proud and honored to
introduce a revolutionary product
manscaped
these are guys that specially engineer
products for shaving your dick and balls
yes I said that right now if you first
of all I almost at this point have even
stopped because I just I cut my shaft
and I don't know why it's I know it's
ordered every time I'm always cutting my
shaft when I'm trying to like shave
everything down there and it's like it's
so and my balls - and it's so painful
it's more than painful it's just like
you were like I just cut my dick in my
balls and there's like a little blood -
it's like it's just such a [ __ ] it's
like you don't ever want to see blood
near your dick or your balls but that's
why manscaped has come in and let me
tell you another problem I'll [ __ ] I
have my whole life use my beard trimmer
on my pubes that fact but what amount so
what else am I supposed to do you know I
usually do before taking a shower so
okay now we've got it all figured out
right did you know I did you know I did
I send that what were you did you have
anything you never confronted me about
it I was thinking like you described it
what can you do you take a shower
it's not like I'm walking around with
with pubes on my face
you know I shower but we don't have
issues anymore because we've got
manscaped let me pull this sweet little
thing out this is the one that you used
to escape look at that fat guard baby to
keep those [ __ ] that chef nice and
clean okay right here boy you need that
nice clean clean look at this this is
called the plow this thing is clean it's
safe and I'm telling you this is
specially engineered by NASA scientists
like how ventas it looks because
sometimes you got to keep it real
sometimes you get too fancy and then all
of a sudden you're cutting your dick and
balls and you're bleeding oh let me tell
you about this manscaped has redesigned
the electric trimmer it's their lawn
mower 2.0 proprietary skin safe
technology so this trimmer won't Nick
are
nag you're nuts I'm telling you it's so
important manscaping accidents are
finally a thing of the past and don't
use the same trimmer on your face as
you're using on your balls they're
hitting all the same spots they know
exactly that's just nasty I couldn't
agree more and trust me my pubes do not
smell like a [ __ ] you know loose off
spring meadow ok manscaped also has the
crop preserver an anti chafing ball
deodorant and moisturizer hold the phone
crop preserver this is it anti chafe
Baldy odor and moisturizer give me a
second you already put deodorant on your
armpits why not put deodorant on yours
the smelliest part of your body amen
brother
what is this corrupt Reviver toner and
refresher let's get small oh my god if
my dick smelled like that you would
never get off it get 20% off plus free
shipping with code h3 at manscaped
dot-com always use the right tools for
the job your balls will thank you get
20% off and free shipping with code h3
at manscaped dot-com that's 20% off and
free shipping at manscape comm with code
h3
all right now since we're on the topic
of dick and balls let me let me support
them in a different way me undo saw
breathable I've been shopping for
underwear and it's all awful like I've
used the me undies and I'm like well
what else is out there there's nothing
on par with these me undies in terms of
soft breathable fabric I'll tell you the
problem I have
it's the waistband this part here the
waist it's like it feels so coarse and
awful on my body how hard is it me and
these are the only one that's figured
out you got to make the waistband soft
you got to make it breathable you got to
make it all feel good that's why me
undies is the best underwear in the game
and if you were already taking the time
to clean your dick and balls to make it
look and smell great then you better
wrap it up nicely to like a Christmas
present do you know what I'm saying Gila
yeah Allah knows exactly what I'm
talking about me undies it's a micro
modal ever heard of that it's like what
was the name of that for Bray me by
vibranium that was like what they used
in black panther that magic [ __ ] from
space vibranium bro it micro modal's the
same [ __ ]
these guys have sizes extra small to
four X L holy 4 XL - probably go down to
the toes dude sometimes they get
underwear so big it Peaks out the bottom
of my shorts that's a sexy look that I
heard you all rock me undies has got
five new silhouettes with the feel free
collection for web man designed for
every type of body in mind and a feather
white weight waistband that makes you
feel free undie exhaustion begone where
is that a technical on the exhaustion
new prints drop every Tuesday so you'll
never run out of ways to express
yourself look at listen let me just be
honest I'm not expressing myself through
my underwear
okay I'm wearing this as comfortable as
hell I love the prints yeah but I'm not
I'm not expressing myself
reminds me of that scene from the office
our office we'd like you want to express
yourself don't you okay pens yeah
they're cool I mean listen I'm listen
I'm talking about the underwear itself
is fantastic Plus members get an
exclusive print at the beginning of
every month these prints are fun but
they
also offer classic color don't always
play by the rules [ __ ] I
included that me and he's just launched
white mmm-hmm they said gasp after Labor
Day white underwear don't wear white
underwear cuz you're gonna get [ __ ]
stains all night it's gonna bear saying
I would I would never wear white on door
don't do it just don't do it to yourself
mandis has a great offer for my
listeners for any first-time purchase
you get 50% off and free shipping oh and
guess what there's 100% satisfaction
guarantee so is it the most comfortable
breathable best a piece of underwear
you've ever tried on you just send it
back and you get money back so that's a
frickin hundred percent guaranteed you
lose dude 50% off free shipping 100%
satisfaction guaranteed go to Mandy's
comm slash h3 that's me andis calm slash
h3 mwah Cheers
welcome back everybody so we're talking
about me being fat hey ever lose weight
yeah we're talking about how you're not
that fat but you need to get help three
monster
I'm giving and you know what right now
right now oh you got the smoothie recipe
on my phone you're getting Saudia recipe
all right that one's gonna taste like a
chocolate shake that's the one then I'll
give you my movie all right this is from
Bill almond milk I love almond milk ice
of ice there you go that's it that's all
this banana almond butter yeah what is
maca powder maca powder you can get that
it like a GNC or something like that
it's like a protein okay protein powder
and cinnamon yeah that's it and
delicious it is delicious in it but it's
not gonna send your salt is Nia now
could be chasing salt and sugar all day
like a junkie so then you do that and
then in between your your your breakfast
and lunch you just have like like fruit
and almonds and stuff like that and you
know I kind of eat I have like I had an
interest in this and he gave me all of
these meals and I just picked out like
you know three or four of my favorite
for each time like lunch and breakfast
I'm not too good with the dinner ones I
got to get back into those but if you
just have like two or three of those you
just sort of rotate them and then every
once in a while even if every 3-4 days
you just go out like people always try
to say you have a cheat day that I have
heard you have a cheat meal that's what
you have you know because you can you've
you [ __ ] up for a whole day dude that
can turn in bad even go a whole year if
you don't if you don't understand
no cravings and what your body is
telling you like I've really learned
what the diction addiction is just
simply doing something that you don't
want to be doing like I don't want to be
doing like me with cigars like I didn't
want to smoke last night and I did and
it's just like so there's a form of
addiction there it's like I wake up like
I need a cigar man but I have a problem
I have to address the fact that I have
to be driving the ship I mean like I
said once every two weeks craving okay
and now you just you know I'm sliding
off the rails here so you just have to
UM I'd love to quit those [ __ ] things
I really should so that's you know
there's always something but then it's
like I haven't drank in almost a year
oh really no yeah but it's sight like so
then it's just because at the end of the
day you'd like well what it is is you
open Pandora's box where you started
getting a buzz mm-hmm so then you start
you have to stay like straight edge to
the point that you don't think because
you know basically for the first 17
years of my life I was straightedge cuz
you know I was like I was a baby
yeah and then you know I wasn't like oh
god what a day at the playground I need
a drink you know I mean there was none
of that but then once you get into that
world it's just like you know there's
just so little information about how
once you go off on your own how you have
to be your own parent you have to say
it's time to go home it's time to go bed
let me go to bed you need an inn like
all of a sudden it's just that
overwhelming sense of freedom if you
don't have your parents you're not in
school anymore I don't have to [ __ ]
read ever anymore I love cookies how my
[ __ ] box if I sit here and eat them
no it's nobody's telling me what to do
when you start sitting there thinking
you're a rebel and it's just like do you
ever feel like when you're like for
example I don't I don't enjoy weed I
wish I enjoyed weed man oh it makes me
feel like [ __ ] I don't know I don't even
joy drinking it makes me feel like [ __ ]
and then it's like all I have are these
hamburgers it's the only job a lot to
live I have a lot to live for
no but I know what I mean like it's like
that's how my cigars are it's exactly
it's like look I go let me have this one
thing yeah but it's bad really bad yeah
but I eat a lot of [ __ ] Egg McMuffins
dude yeah I mean that's it's the worst
[ __ ] way ever to start your day guys
salt is just gonna be through the roof I
never thought about it like that yeah
it's like flying a [ __ ] plane and you
just go straight level I'm gonna hit
that smoothie straight level and boring
and then then I got a green one a green
smoothie that's great now I do it I do
those I want the green smoothie can I
get the green smoothie yeah I'll give
you that one I'm also will tell me so
tummy's wanna zekiel bread you put a
little musty make no setup a little
mustard on it and they just put some
spinach leaves on it and then make an
egg over easy put that on oh of [ __ ] huh
yeah it's up yeah like but then just
don't salt the [ __ ] out of the egg cuz
then you're gonna wake up you never
thought of
I never thought about the salt as an
issue because others no [ __ ] calories
and salt
no it's what it does what it's gonna
it's gonna it's gonna it's going to the
cravings and then your body's just gonna
start going like yeah yeah you know and
the reality is is you just have to just
kind of push through that it's like 8 to
15 minutes you just have to push through
that row and get to the other side yeah
drink some water and in start thinking
sane again and it's like this so much
[ __ ] my phone I'm addicted to my phone I
just like on that phone this is messing
with my stuff you know there's another
thing I did you know I [ __ ] went out
my family and I was just sitting there
answering all these emails so so so
excited that people liked my special
yeah and I was like I was like I was
there but I wasn't there
yeah and it's just like I literally make
fun of people like that in my act it's
like the biggest [ __ ] hypocrite ever
so we're all hypocrites yeah but you
were mentioning that god when we were
when we were on break you said something
oh that the McDonald's people are
jealous of heroin yeah well I mean I
know I want to say like literally like
something blasphemous and those [ __ ]
lunatic sue me but like well that food
companies yeah yeah like something I'd
read one time really stuck with me that
they they looked at hardcore drugs no
and junkies with envy go and we want
people it's case so they they call it
like we want our food to have a
craveability right that's like I mean
one time when they would they would did
this one team had a bounty you know if
you knock out a player on another team
of football team so rather than saying
that he goes if I need to know if you
guys are willing to compete at the level
that we need you to compete there's no
one's gonna say like right then it's
just I mean like just [ __ ] try to
injure people and I would never say
that's what I want you we want our food
to have a craveability and that's why I
like all of that [ __ ] food that [ __ ]
that's is bad like you give me a
I start Oreo cookies and I well I don't
that sleeve could be from here to my
house it's like a bender I'm a food
bender yeah
we need like a sober person goes no you
take a sip and you're [ __ ] with ice
cream you can't take the pint to the
couch right if you just take it and
you're coop out what you're gonna have
and try to say and you have to be in the
right mindset like okay I'm doing this
at least for me know what I learned with
like booze which is why I stopped was
because I'm not like a addictive in the
classic case but I am like if it's in
the house I'm gonna consume it right so
I don't have the you know I don't have
any cigars in the house anymore
I kind of have some high-end booze I
just can't throw it out because it cost
me so much [ __ ] money but like I walk
by it now I don't even see it it's like
it's like books on the shelf it's like
I'm not reading though it is kind of a
you know I'm trying to keep staring into
my new drug is eight hours sleep which
this week doing all this pressing [ __ ] I
haven't really gotten but like there is
there really is yeah eight hours sleep
is the greatest [ __ ] is the greatest
thing ever once you once you have a kid
and but I will say though you know
knocking out all your vices it's the
greatest morning you'll ever have in the
worst evenings every single day yeah you
know I feel like I'm 15 years younger
this is great and then just you know the
day hits you and all the [ __ ] that
happens during the day and then there's
just always that time like ah God you
know and you see beer commercials you
like god that looks delicious it's all
happy and beautiful yeah best [ __ ]
thing that's what I'm saying and like
for me it's a cheeseburger but okay I
admit it will kill and that will kill me
well you know what you just said that
and there's a cheeseburger place I want
to try out here that I'm gonna probably
go to what is it called I don't want it
because it's you tell me afterwards but
yeah so see here's where my mind is it's
like it's Friday we got it we got
through the week baby we go out and make
them that smooth just just yeah just try
it just do there tonight the choc I want
then do the green one I'd be fine I'm
excited I won't yeah but you start
eating well nexif fat has nowhere to
hide
it just doesn't it just it's like it's
just over all right you come back on
this show and I'm gonna be skinny and
I'm gonna call it the bill burr
Ethan is no longer fat no here's a guy I
gave you like literally I just scraped
the surface okay and what you want to do
is get a nutritionist do not listen to
your listeners who's gonna be these
about almond milk it owns and it's gonna
be a zillion things so yeah that's why I
got a nutritionist because if you go on
and you try to learn yourself on the
internet and you don't know what you're
doing just the first like three pages
are all dominated by evil food which is
like now you know and then trying to fit
it's like trying to give money to a
charity right a funny I know that this
is a little [ __ ] how do I know it's just
so I think I do need to get a
nutritionist angry but I you know I try
to diet where I got a personal trainer
and she's like I want you to eat high
fat ground beef cheese avocado I was
like are you sure this is gonna make me
lose weight that what you mean like it's
like the nut will [ __ ] out of [ __ ]
like what's your blah I think that what
they do is a lot of those personal
trails what they have is they have down
to like a formula how to have you do
like a Biggest Loser weight drop hmm and
like how to quickly just cut things down
and look amazing blah blah
I don't like I really it's not
sustainable yeah scared the hell out of
me when she was like everything you just
sounded like how is this gonna move
through my body yeah yeah what is the
lubricant where is the what is going to
get me oh drink a stick of butter raw
bacon and Duncan and butter juice
everything was a lie that you were told
this is either a hundred percent writer
I'm going to Jonestown so that might and
I don't know anything about that diet
but I found what I've been doing is been
working from you okay try it out it's
opening a house healthy reasonable human
being diet yet if you just like really
just you know and and then once you
could get yourself into shape if you
just kind of stay on the diet right just
stay like cuz I did this like a year ago
and I quit drinking and everything I've
pretty much you know I would always go
up to like a buck ninety and then booked
it and I go down to 168 people ago my
god you look sick and out guys
now good hey I can have a cheeseburger
then I got the [ __ ] crack that's
that's yeah so that thing or have a
great week and then it's the weekend is
like the weekend then it's back alright
yeah LeBron I'm gonna I'm doing it I
like it I've never thought to get it
just to help you out you've made that
point three times and he's gonna fire up
his end that's alright I'm telling ya
choose inside you're right you're right
no I know she's right that's okay but
you know you look like you just had a
kid I mean come on man you gotta do
something I wish I was pregnant I could
just lose this way immediately you know
what I mean isn't quite work that way
but the thing is that Yili doesn't
understand and people like okay I'll
shut up let's not have a fight here I'm
here to promote my special I think this
is an important point she doesn't have
the fat disease that I have she's like
Ethan what are you just a comes the
excuses yes I'm just I believe what we
do I see it isn't I leave with Carter
because you haven't she I've not heard
you this it's not you know it's harder
the the crying adults that have to sew
together our our clothes in a sweatshop
that's what difficult ok you live in
America you don't have to stand in bread
lines or anything like that
no you know something I'm serious if you
look over your shoulder every once in a
while you'll see how fortune
you are it's just you haven't that what
it is is you're so [ __ ] bogged down
by all the mistakes that you've thrown
down your [ __ ] pie hole okay yeah I'm
just being blunt here know that it's
hard to get up off the couch it is it's
like the fur if you haven't tried to
touch your toes and forever the first
time you do it you're never gonna want
to do it again but it's all just like I
remember seeing this thing about like
addiction was saying that junkies
basically will will go through 30 years
after 30 years of misery to just avoid
one week of Hell so all you got to do is
you just got it you got to get the
locomotive going now what happens is
you're gonna get it addicted to like I
got myself to the point when I'm eating
right and everything that if something
has too much sugar into him like whoa
what what what is wrong with that I'm
totally like peanut butter mm-hmm and my
whole life I never noticed that and I
used to think like oh I just have a
sweet tooth you know what I mean my dad
has a sweet tooth I got it from him it's
like no he was cooking the meals
everybody it's like he's passing on
through yeah here's the works kid tie
yourself off bill burr ladies and
gentlemen fat shaming me here on my own
show no I'm kidding my place of love
yeah I know I'm fat nobody know
everybody I'm the fat listen you're not
that nice yeah and that's the thing dude
okay and this is a little bit of
self-loathing cuz you wear horizontal
stripes well and look at my gut do you
see how my gut is like like you don't
sit like I mean then you get yourself a
masseuse work out all the [ __ ] [ __ ]
gristle and crap you got in your body
it's amazing then you start stretching
stretching stretching and I'm at the age
now if I don't do it every three days
like all of a sudden like everything
just like tightens up cuz I'm older
right and it's like I'll be sitting on
the couch watching TV for like you know
what I don't think me in an hour forty
minutes or something and when I stand up
it feels like the first step of the day
you know that first step in the day when
you got to Betty like oh my god am I
gonna blow out my
one for you all old man before you get
out of bed in the morning all right take
your toes boy animate your knees all
right feel like you know what how long
you can stay damn that's that like fifty
to forty seconds then point it the other
way gently go that's some old mansion
counterclockwise and then clockwise and
that first step to the bathroom with
butter I'm doing that right now but you
know you know what I noticed and eally
you're not gonna like the sound of this
I was in the shower recently I'm at the
fattest I've been probably my whole life
and I realized to see my penis I had to
kind of lean over a little bit like oh
you're back when you can't see your own
penis mm-hmm I always saw that's felt
that's a little overrated I think your
dick should be like a rect at some level
cuz they think [ __ ] well I'll town
it's inherently not it's gonna lead you
to believe me
[Laughter]
couple sports fans yeah I shouldn't
you're not that bad you're not that but
I'm telling you like you could like you
you actually have the perfect body type
for the before and after you're not like
I need surgery and I got flap on this
[ __ ] nobody has to cut you out of your
shed all right your shame shed were you
sitting there I know that's why I spend
my whole day do you know what's the
worst thing as far as food that just
came out and over I don't know when the
last year so I finally noticed them is
those those those like bags of M&Ms that
you could literally that big enough to
feed a horse with you know the same and
they say family size you know people are
just getting those on a flight just just
the misery of being on uh just just like
a hundred bags of glory but he was kind
of Eminem's you like classic or peanut
butter or the I like the peanut
but ever since they came out with the
almond ones your almond guy yeah but I
like the but I know I like when I go to
the movies I always I get the small
popcorn and then I get the the yellow
M&Ms that's the ones like you poor man
you know people do that poor people poor
the MS in the popcorn I don't get that
it's the sugar salt that's the speedball
but they like kobe fatty
it literally is that's what the like I
didn't know anything about you know
eating something salty then you want
some sugar I'd ever do that until I had
a fat roommate and he told me about it
he knew buns like do you have any eights
yeah yeah that's well then and then ever
since he [ __ ] taught me that he
taught me he taught me how to [ __ ] it
what's he saying it T like how to get
high cuz he's like a man you know how
you won't really want a sugar yeah no
that's that's the [ __ ] thing like I
used to do a bit about that in my act
help all of that [ __ ] like when I was a
kid a candy bar was a candy bar and a
[ __ ] ice cream was ice cream right
okay fat people who just went over the
rails were the one thing like what if I
take this and stick it in that okay then
the ice cream rip them off right but
they never sued him because they were so
ashamed to waddle up and be like hey I
came up with that [ __ ] that some of my
fat friends have done with food I mean
it's it's like it's not even like
mainstream porn it's like the feds
should come in and grab your phone call
your neighbors that you moved in you
have to tell your neighbors that you
moved into that neighborhood so when
they go to their barbecue they know what
the [ __ ] they're in important but you
can um Tony Mann you can like really if
you get a nutritionist it's everything
anything else you would like you know if
you want to learn something you know if
you learn how to fight you go to like a
dojo and somebody learns how to fight
this [ __ ] [ __ ] we try to figure it
out or you talk to somebody at a bar
going you know it's good you know it's
good eat the pistachios with the shells
because they are oh yeah I have to [ __ ]
that I told you is probably wrong
because I'm pear I'm trying but it
sounds good
it makes sense it's all whole
I'm gonna shrink the shakes yeah you
know what you want it you do want it I
was gonna say that I had she'll probably
make it fly what a duty I would I would
not maybe you know oh my god the whole
diet computer sounds like the beginning
of a hit love song if you make me a
smoothie I was gonna say was a shock to
me the food here I'm moving from Israel
seeing the food here like breakfast
people eat like like okay eggs and
pancake but it's not just one pancake
they'll get like a pile of Pancakes
the mayor weird like a stick of butter
you just go back we're a pile you really
inscribe no they're calling it breakfast
yeah the menu wait a minute what am i
doing pancakes but it it's true that's
that's America to me they'll take
something and they'll like take it
really far and you know what I call it I
call that nap food when I see like
pancakes waffles all that [ __ ] with
butter and syrup that is nap food you're
gonna go oh my god this is amazing and
you you're lucky if you don't [ __ ]
drive into a tree your apartment of
houses wait you just have to be like
conscious of it I mean in Israel
breakfast is in socks and and and the
world is stacked against me
because when I go to the grocery store
when I go wherever even if I want to go
out to eat it's like all these
[ __ ] gotta play me dirty yeah
they're gonna but you know what it just
takes so listen most like people are
starving around the world like that so
the idea they were born in America all
right they can they got their own issues
okay they gonna like a different issues
I know we do like this is like the most
prickly you've been on your [ __ ] this
is a big thing this is it this is your
mom you know what you're gonna realize a
lot of times you think it's a mountain
and all you're doing is stepping up on a
curb I'm telling you you just use
beautiful yeah you really think that
it's just you did get you are motivated
because that you are motivating me you
know we think much as a dick as I am I
root for people I know I don't like
seeing them
well we're nearing an hour okay and I
think we fixed we daddy helped me out at
all well guys we paper tiger for
Christ's sake go watch it on that go
it's a masterpiece
it's such a fun time such a great great
I've got to give credit in all the thing
and roof emili´s is the one that took at
that picture of me
[Laughter]
yeah warms my heart when that came here
afterwards yeah yeah well you know I
hope people see the picture that would
mean that they watched it they watch the
mandalorian Wow Disney Plus actually
found a way to make my make me pay for a
Disney streaming platform I never I'm
not gonna lie to you even if I wasn't in
that I would I would be like I think we
gotta get I think I'm gonna get that
right well never always makes everything
that he makes I yeah you know I've
always liked and I just when I saw this
man he's like a total like Star Wars
free yeah it's so it's it's in guess it
is in good hands those Disney guys know
to make them money huh those
[ __ ] know how to make a dollar
well there's a reason they've been
around forever did you ever think that
Walt Disney he was making these little
mouse cartoons
stop that it would become like one of
the biggest most powerful corporations
in the world like how did that you know
the carousel in Griffith Park do you
know well you know you'll know it cuz
you got a kid yeah I you know got a kid
so you find out where the carousels are
and that was that was originally was in
San Diego and then it moved up they
moved it up to Griffith Park and that
was the thing that he wrote on and that
gave him the idea of to make Disneyland
hmm really
cool everybody like I do on it and stuff
in Hollywood blood was like oh is that
what that like yeah you noticed that
random people you run into you notice
this phenomenon that outside LA everyone
shits on LA and inside LA nobody well
depends on how you're doing in this
business again if you're not doing well
in this business really there's no fake
people you know New York there's so much
realer there's so honest down there on
Wall Street right it's just more like
where you're happy or whatever but then
you can like go to a place and not be
happy there and not have to [ __ ] all
over it and think that everybody you
know if you're doing stand-up it's ok I
guess to kind of make jokes about it but
like you know that's it's not it's not a
happy way to go through the world like
that's why I love traveling with New
Yorkers because they come from this
giant city and they have such a small
time view of the world and if they
literally cannot do exactly what they do
on their [ __ ] block they could go to
tell you day it was like we're in Texas
get some Tex Mex yeah learn how to ride
a horse you shoot a gun do what they do
here yeah go see a [ __ ] band I mean
find out like it's not like there's
people like people will have fun
wherever they're at find out what the
[ __ ] they do for fun and then even if
you're not into it you get that
experience but to just sit there you
know like I just love like I always
stuff going on the road and like people
be like wanting to go to like a [ __ ]
food chain the same one that's like
right down the street I get it that
maybe if you're lonely or whatever
there's familiarity of it but it's just
kind of like you don't want to try to
find out like we yeah well it's a spot
yeah let's try to go to the spot before
Guy Fieri blows it up and is 9,000
people in the line you know but I I'm
native to SoCal and I didn't know that
people talk [ __ ] about LA till I lived
in New York for a year and everybody
there it's like the butt of every joke
is Los Angeles and it shocked the hell
out of me I didn't know that there was
that that's like really yeah yeah it
shocked the hell you like that LA has a
fight phone
anybody I grew up here and I never well
you didn't grow up laying the Torah it's
Klaus so cow whatever but you know I've
been in California that makes sense yeah
I was like oh man everybody hates LA I
love it they don't even know what they
hate a lot of them look if you lived
here and you hated it then I'll be that
guy yeah but so many people are going
out there little plastic plug component
people you know I do love his plastic
surgery is now a plague across the
entire Beverly Hills than the LA
stereotype you see it there no they get
a bad rap dude go down to Orange County
go to Dallas go to Miami do anything
crazy even like the guys like just it's
unbelievable I think I'm now some people
take it so far I mean it must be some
kind of like psychological disease
because they see themselves not as we
see them right I do I think I literally
think it's like just like getting
tattoos
just like into it because their face
start to look like they were like stung
by a bee
do people get tattoos on their face now
I know but like like the face was the
Forbidden Zone even like the like but
when I was a kid if he had sleeve
tattoos you know what I mean that means
you were like in a biker gang you
[ __ ] somebody like you were a badass
but even those guys back in the day they
didn't [ __ ] with their face you know
yeah I'd say they want to look pretty in
that mug shot right I feel like it's
it's gun to the extreme and now it's
gonna go like out of fashion that's my
opinion
yeah I think it the it's better I don't
want another Ashley's people maybe but
like god damn like this is one famous
guy that's a disease that's not normal
he was a really good-looking guy that's
the now most of these people were really
very very very beautiful like he
literally looks like he's wearing like a
presidential windows president of mass
the Ronald Reagan wonder does oh I mean
this one I mean again I'm not I'm not
you know everyone's got their issues
right but well I think with these ones
if you notice they were really
attractive when they were younger and
maybe that was a lot of their currency
or whatever and then they just trying
that's the great thing about being a
[ __ ] for your whole life thank you
age great would you look
great that's cuz I look like [ __ ] when I
was young but actually she's a hundred
and fifty so I don't know maybe we
should uh maybe she does look good
you know it's my more of a problem for
me is seeing younger people now like
this is different but I feel like now
it's in fashion for young people my
girls they get all the feelers their
lips
it's a shame most of those people you're
right I shouldn't have ever pulled that
up let's get it listen and let's close
this before I look you little nervous
you're not getting your burgers I'm
telling you you know what I have a feel
for yourself this morning for burgers
had two hard-boiled eggs and unsweetened
oatmeal not bad yeah thank you
it sounds a little sad a hard-boiled egg
is that that's a tough yeah that's a
tough one
now here's some I heard in a bar was
that you you you want the yolk because
the yolk that's where all the nutrition
is in but then if you have it
hard-boiled you kind of cook the [ __ ]
out of the neutral don't tell me that I
don't even know if that's true I can't I
literally heard somebody say it and now
I'm saying it to you and now you my
enjoyment a heart boil their
nutritionists don't listen to a [ __ ]
comedian fair enough guys bill burr
paper tiger Netflix bill burr calm catch
him on tour
mandalorian Disney got us all as usual
those [ __ ]
no one is still my good money that's
about it all we got to say about that
almond shake drinking machine yeah
here's the thing probably knew I I would
I would start like a journal on what you
want to do and happen and write down
what you want to accomplish that day
because this [ __ ] in here is [ __ ]
that is on a loop yeah and it'll really
easily spin you off if you really it's
like the level of dedication you know
what I mean that's why all those shows
it so funny where they try to fix a
family in one episode all those
self-value need to stop doing this and
you need to stop doing that alright Joe
it's just like
I think he just did a dr. Phil yes he's
one of my favorite my favorite thing he
did recently Kevin Hartz out of the
hospital so he did this thing about when
you know talking about old cars and it's
just like I was just going with the foot
he starts out he's like oh I didn't I
don't know Kevin Hart I got a big house
in an old car and I want to talk about
new cars really did you just want to
show off how funniest things I saw a
comedian do that at a benefit because it
was a bunch of industry there and they
saw it it was like a you know I get
industry move and they came up on stage
you know I didn't know so-and-so but I
you know I always heard he's like I
don't know Kevin Hart
I'm like a catchphrase in my house now
when you don't even what the [ __ ] you
all right all right thank you very much
wish you all the best all good thing and
and God's blessings to you and see you
next week yeah we're good I got we have
some smoothie chat to get to so we're
gonna wish you guys I do appreciate
y'all and take care
[Music]
[Applause]